hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast association of biotin
ingestion with performance of hormone
and non hormone assays in healthy adults
presented by dr. Danny Lee director of
clinical chemistry an assistant
professor of laboratory medicine and
pathology University of Minnesota I mix
a few tears of lab roots and that will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by dear Soren for more
information on their sponsor please
visit www.disabilitydenials.com for
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I'd like
to now introduce our presenter dr. Lee
you may begin your presentation thank
you for that nice introduction today I
would like to talk about biotech Jessen
and interfere with lab tests
so for disclosure I research I received
research funding from NIH Alzheimer's
Association
at CDC and I also received speaking on
Ettore inform Avid's Diagnostics dates
soren and consulting from Roche
Diagnostics so the objectives of my talk
are listed here so the primary objective
is to review mechanisms and factors that
determine high dose biote interference
with lab tests and I would like to use
two of my publications to to talk about
on this first objective and then second
that I like to you know describe this
increasing trend of high dose biotin use
and health and medical benefits and then
thirdly I like to explain that how this
continuing trends that may be a game
changer of the clinical diagnostic
industry and lastly I want to make a
case for why more research is needed to
understand the nutritional and
therapeutic value of bio team so so the
background story of this talk and some
of you may already know is that in
November 2017 FDA issued a warning
concerning bout interference with lab
tests this is because that many of the
lab tests that are immunoassay that
exploit the binding between biotin and
strim additi so what is bio team
well biotin is actually known as a
vitamin b7 or so people know bio team in
terms of its strong binding to sturby
Avenue and this strong binding is
actually utilized in many automated
immunoassay platforms to improve as a
performance so here is just a list of
the major diagnostic
instrument that using the clinical lab
that use peyote Nets trouble acting
finding and I will talk about the
mechanism and of how biotene interfere
with those essays on those instrument
later so so you may wonder okay so the
story is that Valentin when you take
high dose that would interfere waste lab
tests and so what about you know the
natural level of bio teaming Bloods so
natural blood level of bio team actually
is actually very low and there at the
range of nano gram per mil that usually
that is too low to cause any
interference however that recently that
there's a trend of you know taking very
high dose of bio team for health and
medical reasons so for those bio team
known as super vitamin and people taking
it in a very large quantities such as 5
10 even 20 milligram daily will help
with their you know nail and hair growth
and and for other reasons so um and in
addition to those health and beauty and
cosmetic reasons that there are so
therapeutic reasons that why people are
taking large doses of biotin such as for
treatments of biotin deficiency for
diabetic neuropathy and also there's
faith 3 clinical trials that of using
biotene and a daily dose of 300
milligram for treatment of multiple
cirrhosis so
there's a lot of you know reasons why
people take peyote and now I've very
large dose so the question is that can
high dose biotin screwed up lab test
results and if so how
because if we so far we talked about
biotin as the important components that
in many of those immunoassay tests that
use in the clinical lab and historically
that because there's no large use of
large dose of bio T therefore the
natural level vial team which is very
low in the blood is not going to cause
any interference however there's a
recent trend of using large dose of
biotin that due to medical and health
reasons and so that this new trend is
whether it's going to cause the lab
tests interference so the answer of this
question is yes and we're going to
actually demonstrate this that using
this case that I published in 2009 so
this is a case of 64 year old female
with long-standing end stage renal
disease and she came for you back to the
hospital for evaluation of her renal
osteodystrophy was particularly
concerned for a dynamic Byrne disease so
she was in the hospital and was seen by
endocrinologist who is trying to figure
out whether she has either we know
osteodystrophy or a dynamic bone disease
which has very different presentation in
terms of the lab tests particularly the
lab tests
that would be helpful evaluating her
with the PTH parathyroid hormone and
alkaline phosphatase so for differential
diagnosis if she had renal
osteodystrophy her PTH and alkaline
phosphatase were both going to be
elevated on the other hand if she had a
dynamic bone disease her PTH and
alkaline phosphatase will be both
you know decreased so what treat what
actually was that discrepant
in her case and also the reason that her
endocrinologist a Content contacted the
lab is that in her case the PTH was
decreased but alkaline phosphatase was
increased so this scenario that was
inconsistent with either picture so long
story short that the lab helped the
endocrinologist with investigation so we
first that actually looked at the
medical chart and realizing that the
patient has been taking large doses of
19 10 milligram daily for treatment of
her restless leg syndrome and so knowing
that biotene could be interfere with
this test of PTH so we performed a lot
of lab investigation and and then but in
order to confirm this we did ask the
patient and stop taking bio team for two
weeks and after two weeks on the patient
came back and now the PTH results has
gone up
so now the picture of pth is actually
consistent with the elevated alkaline
phosphatase so here I don't have time to
go into a lot of detail of the
investigation but to say that this was
actually the first case that published
in United States that demonstrating the
biotin intake interfere with lab tests
in this case that the lab test involved
was the parathyroid hormone test so so
you may want to know okay so what is
then the mechanisms of bio change of
your interference
so this slide actually shows you the
mechanism so as I mentioned before that
many of those automated immunoassay
platform that you know take advantage of
the strong binding between stability and
a bio team so many of those system that
used to obtain coded magnetic beads to
capture biotinylated immuno complex of
interest in this case PTH
so in so imagine that when you have
excessive amount of biotin presence in a
blood sample as a result of taking a
very large dose of biotene that those
excessive amount of biotin that would
actually compete binding to those beads
and as a result of that competition
there was less of those analyte of
interest that will ended up finding with
the magnetic beads and then this
reduction of finding them result a
result as decreased sa signal so
depending on the you know direct
depending on the amino acid design the
decreased as a signal either cause cause
decreased results in the sandwiched
immune sa or falsely increase the
results in competitive in manassas a
because the relationship between the
analyte concentration and then the
readout so so in this case that PTH is
measured by a sandwich immunity and
therefore the excessive dieting presence
in the sample will cause falsely low PTU
PTH result which is consistent with with
what we saw in the case so so far that
um you know I actually meant you know
using this case that I published to
demonstrate the biotin interference and
and then the mechanisms and then also
the direction of interference when it
happens to sandwich immunizes as well as
competitive in your essay so so the next
question is then um so how many of the
clinical tests are actually affected in
healthy adults when take large doses of
peyote well so in order to answer this
question so that we actually design the
study but before I talk about this study
um you know I want to take a step back
and then just to you know to think about
this question so um we talked about that
there's many clinical tests that
utilizing biotin and strip Avenue right
so we also know that it's possible not
all the tests
utilizing biotene and stir bounding
would be affected and the impact that
made depending on many different factors
so so this study is really designed to
answer the question that when a
individual that take a large dose
abouting home and then how many texts
are actually affected by the amount of
biotin present in the blood so in order
to do this study that we recruited about
seven healthy adults that we asked them
to take biotin for six four six seven
days and then stop taking biotin for
seven days and for each participant's
that we take there for example from
baseline seven days after taking bio
teams and then seven days are after stop
taking bio teens so each participant's
we have three blood samples collected or
so we want to evaluate as many tests
that you know possible so in this case
that we reached out to you know many
different clinical labs that so
altogether in this study we evaluated
eleven tests measured by 37 sa over for
diagnostic systems and so so here is the
summary of the study results um
23 of those assay are prone to biotin
interference so what that means is that
those were the assays that actually did
use bio team and Stuber a body as part
of their mechanism we are so we found
that in this study about nine of them
were actually affected by the biting is
Jess tchen of
10 milligrams daily and also as part of
the control we included 14 assays I'm
not promoting interference meaning that
those are the essays that do not
including biotin finding - stranding as
part of the mechanism and then us as
expected
none of us a wolf was actually affected
so um so now let's go over to actual of
those tests that we validate in this
study so so first we actually you know
included five of those thyroid function
tests that that has been shown by in
literature that they are most likely to
be affected by biotin interference so in
this case that we included you know four
different diagnostic system Kobus
pedro's and vista and Abbot's so the
result here shows as four TSH Kobus and
vetoes are likely are actually when
people are taking biotene their TSH
level well dropped you know
significantly so particularly in the
vetos case that the th level was
significantly decreased and then or so
we also show that when healthy
individual take ten milligrams daily
dose of biotin that their total t-33 t4
and three T's we could also give you
know false result but in contrast with
TSH which this you know signal is
decreased for the competitive assay such
as total t3 3 T 4 or 3 T 3 the actual
impact is falsely increased
our results so this slice basically
summarized that when house the
individual take ten milligrams daily
dose of biotin and they're you know
there's blood samples when you know as a
buy a thyroid function test that can
give results that lead to you know false
increase or false decreased results that
is actually problematic and then other
tests that we evaluating this has that
including you know parathyroid hormone
and anti Pro PMP and vitamin D so again
here shows that when healthy individual
take ten milligram dose of biotin that
if they have a PTH test done by Vito's
instrument that they actually this way
this will actually lead to falsely low
results same thing for me chose anti Pro
PMP for vitamin D that we see here that
the biotin actually would interfere with
koba's vitamin D as a so um
the study that you know we evaluated
many different system at many different
tests so from those two previous slides
that you can see that some tests are
more prone to biting interference than
other tests so in addition to the test
diagnostic system so two additional
factors that may also determine that
biotin interfere wisdom you know is the
dose of biotin that individual is using
as was the timing of the last dose so
this slice actually explained why the
biotin dose matter well this is because
the higher dose of biotin that people
use the higher biotin level level will
be present you know in their blood
sample and therefore cost more you know
interference so therefore that there's a
core positive correlation between biotin
dose as well as bio team you know
interference and also the timing matters
because this figures shows that the you
know the the level of biotin in blood
post dose that so this life shows that
the peak level of IOT reached at about
two hours after the biotin you take and
then gradually decrease as time goes on
so that means that if a sample is taking
at you know the peak time when biotin we
you know level reached add blood that
this is going to cause the most
interference however that if the bio
team you know said if the bottom boy is
taking you know hours and you know let's
say 24 hours after the initial dose then
the chance of the sample that have
interference is much lower so therefore
the timing of the last biotin dose also
would actually affecting the actual
value interference so given all this
information so what what are they
manufacture that what could the
manufacturer do so the manufacture that
who you know produce those tests that
has been very active in terms of you
know publishing information and working
on recommendations so that that more
people are going to be
aware of this situation so the
particularly they are working on
recommending the blood sample the safety
testing of blood sample they trying to
figure out like how long the blood
sample should wait before it's taken
from a individual person after their
last dose of biotene in order to limit
the chance of biotin interference so um
I hope that you know so far that you
would agree that high dose of biotin use
can cause interfere with lab results and
I have you know go over the the
mechanism and also I have you know using
my recent study to demonstrate that they
extend up the problem as well as the
factors that will impact the
interference so then the next question
is you know why is this important why
does this matter
well the number one reason why it
matters is that as you already kind of
seen that many of those clinical
immunoassays that use biotin extracting
interference therefore that a
significant amount of them are prone to
biotin to fairness so another reason
that I haven't covered is that actually
there's an increasing chance of large
dose of biotin supplement use even
though we don't really have the
prevalence and the longitudinal
prevalence data however that this trend
is is in part that reflected by the
number
of case reports that published in
literature over time so over the last 10
and 20 years there is an increasing
trend of case reports that starting from
1996 there is only one case till
recently there's about you know seven
cases that published in 2017 so this
increasing trend of case report that as
its reflecting that you know the
increasing trend of biting news that you
know that we we have seen so so then the
next question that I think would it be
important to for them you know
diagnostic industry to consider is that
if this is this twin of continuing use
of very large dose of biotene that going
to have some sort of impact on the
diagnostic industry well if there's one
test that is going to be very critical
and that that test would be the troponin
so for many of you that either like
medicine community that we know that
Kona is a test that providing critical
information for evaluating heart attack
so and in the in the recent FDA safety
communication that I mentioned very
early on in the talk that FDA actually
single doubts troponin as the test that
and then and particularly this
communication mentioned that FDA
received a report that a patient taking
high levels biotene died follow
you know a false low troponin test when
troponin test is known to hide value so
you know this demonstrating that you
know it's very critical that for
patients that especially when they have
a troponin test you know performed that
we need to know whether they have you
know interference such as troponin
whether they cause interference because
this test providing such critical
information for evaluating patients so
so how much do we know actually that the
potential of you know this test that
would cause trouble in the emergency
department where that most of those
turbulence has been performed so here
recently there's a very nice actually
paper published by Katzman from Mayo
Clinic that demonstrated that biotene
supplement use in patient that presented
to the emergency department so in this
study they evaluated you know this
question in two different ways by using
survey questionnaires as was the
biochemical measurements of biotin
concentration presence in you know
samples so both a method that
demonstrated that there's about seven
percent of people through survey that
indicated their use of bio team and then
also there's about seven point four
percent of those sample that has biotin
level that measured at above ten
nanogram per mil that's known to
interfere with some of the Roche
immunoassays so so this study
complemented with you know the FDA
safety communication that illustrate
that
um peyote interfere with interfere with
with lab tests particularly with
troponin test that could be a issue in
the IT department and so to answer that
questions say you know if there's any
tests that could you know be you know
impactful so that the manufacturer would
consider change you know how they the
method to you know prevent by ot
interference there for you know then
this would be the test that that you
know will change the scenario so um so I
think that from what I've had talked to
before the point that is okay so we now
seen there's a trend of biotin use and
and the trend is increase in the trend
is increasing the way that about seven
percent of the you know people presented
to the IDI Department that use biotin
hinders them about seven percent of the
sample SAT in the eg determine that
could have you know biotin interference
that um you know change the lab results
so so this may have some impact to the
diagnostic industry so then you know
many of you may want to know
so is this trend is going to continue
like um in order to answer that question
I think a different way to look at this
question is is there really a health and
medical benefit of using peyote and why
do people you know taking those large
dose of biotene well um so the
mechanisms that biotin actually could
you know convey health benefits are
really unknown
historically we know that biotene are
cofactors of many enzymes that are
important in mitochondria so the
assumption is that taking large doses
abouting can potentially boost energy
production and so that is good for that
will give a lot of health benefit
however that um really there's not a
clinical study that actually even proven
value of the medical or you know health
benefit abiding so more research is
needed in particularly that more
research is really needed to understand
that whether taking bio team would
actually keep people better hell and
health girls and nail growth despite
that there's lack of those evidence that
is still there some study shows that 66%
of the dermatologists that would
recommend dietary supplements including
biotin to their patient to improve their
skin health help hair and nail and also
this is not only limited in the United
States but in other countries such as
Saudi Arabia like 60% of the
dermatologist or so we you know
recommend treating hair loss with
vitamins including biotene so um you
know despite lack of evidence that
doctors recommends supplement use so I
suspect that the trend is going to
continue
so my you know recommendation to the
science community is that we really need
to understand more about the you know
the evidence and gather evidence to to
demonstrate whether there's any you know
health benefits or medical reasons that
taking largers dose of biotin so
so with that I like to summarize this
webinar so I hope that have demonstrated
to you that biotin when taking very
large dose that can interfere with lab
many lab tests and there's you know
three different factors that will
determine whether tests that actually
affected by bio change appearance or not
and and the manufacturers are actually
working on safety testing
recommendations to improve their acid
design to limit by the interference and
then despite the perceived beauty
reasons that we need to know more about
the nutritional and therapeutic value
with that I like to thank my
collaborators for my studies at
University of Minnesota
Fairview Medical Center Boston Medical
Center Children's Mercy Hospital Kansas
City and Johns Hopkins Medical
Institutions thank you for your
attention thank you dr. Lee for your
informative presentation
we're announcer the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
why answers many of your questions as we
have time for now let's get started our
first question is what should a lab do
when asked to investigate a potential
biotin interference so yes so when lab
is asked to investigate a potential I
didn't have time to go into the detail
because um it's not the main focus of
this webinar so um it's investigating
biote interferences it's like
investigating you know any other
interference the first step is to
identify whether the interference is
so there's couple way to do it by say
you know send the sample to test by a
different methodology or perform
dilution on the sample to see that
whether the diluted results and the neat
results who are still comparable so if
there's no evidence of interference that
basically and the investigation there
but if there's discrepancy with results
in such way that you know it's like you
know so then then in order to identify
whether biotene is the cause of the
interferences number one that making
sure that you know patient indeed take
peyote and then number two that's you
can ask you know patients are taking
peyote and then see whether you know the
result change in the direction that
would be more consistent with patient
clinical picture and lastly if you have
you know stove averaging magnetic beads
or Austral adding beads that in the lab
you could actually treat the sample
using the strip and they're a big piece
to remove those excessive amount of
biotin presumably that present in the
sample and then and then we assayed the
you know the sample after the
pretreatment and we move off those fees
and see whether that sample will gives
you the the result that is consistent
with you know you know what was
consistent without peyote interference
so that is you know a way that then or
so to help with you know identify that
that biotene indeed was the cause of
interviews so to summary that you know
first is to identify interference is
present or not and then is to identify
whether biting is the cause of the
interference by asking patient to stop
taking it or using the piece for
treatments and then to confirm that you
know peyote
i remove up the bio tea
you get the you know correct answer
we're gonna have time for one more
question what would you suggest the
emergency doctors do to prevent
misinterpretation of troponin results
due to biotin ear interference well
that's a very challenging question you
know um when when let's say imagine the
patient that do take large dose biotin
Cui's into the emergency room that was
heart attack
the blood is draw for evaluation which
opponent then it's there's a chance that
the fighting defense would cause falsely
low troponin results um you know but the
question is you know what what doctor
would the ET doctor know about it well
so my suggestion that for ET doctors you
know is to maybe well it's to ask
patient whether they take arts doe
society and then if so that then they
know that there's high higher chance
that biotene that you know could
interfere with the test and therefore
that you know consider you know other
ways to investigating whether patient
has a heart attack and also use serial
you know monitor of the troponin level
and then thirdly is that if they have
some other ways to looking at triple
Meghan's using a different method you
know that is not prone to biotene to
Ference that maybe they should also look
at it a different methods so for example
at my mess my hospital the IDI lab that
the IDI acting department has access to
central lab test which is prone to
biting to interference and then I stat
which is not so you know when you when
you have access to different method that
is helpful to providing you know
information that is hopefully pointed
out the right direction well thank you
again dr. Lee do you have any final
comment comments for our audience um I
really appreciate the opportunity to you
know to tell you about this issue of
file t you know ingestion and interfere
with lab tests and then feel free to ask
me questions yeah thank you okay before
we go I would like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their inter
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank lab
roots and are sponsored Eathorne for
underwriting today's educational webcast
don't forget to take a moment to visit
our virtual lab and virtual booth to
find out more about Deus Orange products
and instruments all of our content is
available 24/7
including this webinar until June 25th
of 2019 lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's event until next time goodbye